si vous êtes tintinophiles vous allez
pouvoir devenir air géologue et c'est à
dire tout savoir sur hergé
le premier tome d'une série de cinq
ouvrages qui retrace son oeuvre vient en
effet de sortir
on y découvre la période de 1907 à 1931
et la naissance de tintin qui s'appelait
d'ailleurs au départ
totor yann fossurier richard tripot un
gribouillis non un train qui passe
devant une voiture sous les yeux d'un
garde barrière le premier dessin d'un
enfant de 4 ans qui deviendra quelques
années plus tard le père du célèbre
tintin c'est à la page 11 d'hergé
chronologie d'une oeuvre un livre de
référence qui retrace les jeunes années
du dessinateur bruxellois
né en 1907 au fil des croquis et des
vignettes ont su l'itinéraire d'un
garçon précoce est bonne élève qui
découvre son amour pour le dessin à
travers le scoutisme
il a fait son premier voyage à
l'étranger de manière assez unique avec
ses compagnons scouts et étant déjà
illustrateur dans des revues scouts mais
il emmenait avec lui cet égard des
croquis et y engranger des choses un
signe et otor chef de patrouille
vient-on les bouches en culottes courtes
d'un certain reporter le trait pour
trait c'est la même hypothèse la mer des
trombes d'eau mais mener la même mèche
qui est en-avant tatin d'ailleurs ça
mais devra se relever un peu plus tard
mais quand il qu'il ait créé n'atteint
sa mèche tombe en avant sur le franc
exactement comme tout autre j'étais loin
de me douter évidemment en décidant ces
petites histoires kid qui devait être
sans lendemain
j'étais loin de me douter que ça allait
prendre des proportions ça a pris
aujourd'hui ouvrage publié par philippe
godin s'achève par la publication des
premières aventures de tintin tintin au
pays des soviets en 1929 et surtout
tintin au congo l'année suivante
un album qui divise encore aujourd'hui
les admirateurs des rejets
entendu il voit les populations
congolaises de l'époque comme de grands
enfants comme étant peut-être un peu
sous évaluée à l'époque c'est une vision
ambiante évidemment qu'on peut reprocher
cette chronologie riche de plus de 400
pages nous fait découvrir également un
autre hergé 1 rg illustrateur de presse
au coup de crayon plus travailler un
style très différent de la bande
dessinée quatre nouveaux volumes sont
d'ores et déjà prévues mais les fans de
copains devront patienter la fondation
hergé n'en publiera qu'un seul chaque
année